Este vídeo Recuerda que milito Paul fue
una de las primeras ciudades en caer en
control de las fuerzas rusas después de
la invasión a gran escala iniciada el 24
de febrero de 2022
Tres semanas después muchos de los
trabajadores de la Administración
pública lograron huir y con el tiempo
restablecieron sus operaciones en
saporilla primer punto de llegada de
quienes subían del sur de la provincia
incluido melipoll
Durante este año alrededor del 70% de la
población se vio forzada a dejar la
ciudad Cuál es la razón al día de hoy
hay una crisis humanitaria en la ciudad
y todos los días desaparecen personas
por sus posiciones por Ucrania los
militares rusos los secuestran
había rumores de que los rusos tenían
cuartos de tortura la gente hablaba de
ellos en voz baja no nos atrevíamos a
hacer ningún comentario antirruso porque
había una posibilidad de terminar igual
que muchos jóvenes que eran torturados
en esas cámaras por sus posiciones a
procranianas las autoridades aseguran
que el número de personas que vienen por
ayuda se ha duplicado en las últimas
semanas por varias razones una de ellas
es porque a muchos se les ha finalizado
el dinero pero otra es porque muchos de
ellos esperan poder regresar prontamente
a meritopoli es que uno de los objetivos
de esta contraofensiva que se espera en
las próximas semanas es poder liberar
esta ciudad en el sur de la provincia
cuando los rusos empezaron la invasión
pensaron que los estaban esperando que
los recibirían con flores danzas pan y
sal
pero se enfrentaron a una situación
opuesta hoy por hoy melitol es la
capital de los partisanos podemos ver
como cada semana hay un accidente de los
colaboradores o soldados rusos
esta oficina no solamente se preocupa
por ayudar a quienes se encuentran en
este momento refugiados en la ciudad de
saporilla sino también se ha preocupado
por planear lo que puede ser el día
después cuando la ciudad sea liberada
para eso han creado un cronograma en el
cual tienen jornada por jornada lo que
tendrán que hacer lo que no saben
exactamente Es cuando ese día llegará